Katelyn's just not comfortable with it.
Exactly. I do not need that whole video. Stop.
No, that's a great clip. Click that. Click that. Check.
What were you talking about?
Uh, Cuddy, you're, uh, you know, my majestic new main.
You're still, uh,
faithfully employed, right?
The DOD isn't taking care of you, right?
Mom, I'm not a CEO, right?
That's what I'm saying.
Faithfully employed.
It was probably a choice of the law.
She's thinking about it.
She bugged off the lighthouse, right?
So it's because I'm in college for the lighthouse.
That's a good question.
I wish you were in my band.
So she's a real nice guy.
I'm looking for a special offer.
I wish you wouldn't start a career
until the lighthouse lights is on
and you have people visiting your church.
I don't believe in the current administration's agenda.
I'm sure it was published
against the current administration's agenda.
Yeah, I was going to say, I thought you did a lot of research.
Did you do a lot of research?
Like, there's a good chance
she doesn't have much of a choice in the future.
She could, I believe, like, turn.
That would be another problem.
Someone bring him balls or should I get more money?
Ah, fuck!
Who has the ball bag?
Tyrus, do you have the ball bag?
It's right there.
It's that trash bag.
She's super smart.
She'll get the job.
We could live off my salary for a while.
Forever.
Then he's got...
We could go on trips and shit, you know?
Like, I wouldn't be going to Miami if we were a single-income household.
But, yeah.
Dinner on...